con el sueño americano frustrado y de
regreso a un país que no está listo para
recibirlos en ese limbo se mueven
cientos de migrantes haitianos
deportados de eeuu muchos de ellos
abandonaron la nación hace años después
del terremoto de 2010 y vuelven a un
lugar casi desconocido más pobres
violento e inestable que cuando se
marcharon ante la falta de oportunidades
de volver a emigrar es una posibilidad
pero si no me da ninguna unidad
siempre va andando frente a la mujer
ésta de ahora no tengo que hacer nada
bien desde el domingo eeuu comenzó a
expulsar a cientos de migrantes que
querían ingresar irregularmente al país
algunos denuncian malos tratos
cuando llegamos a eeuu nos pusieron en
detención por cuatro días cuatro días
sin lavarnos los dientes sin ducharnos
solo nos dieron algo de comida como no
queríamos irnos en el bus y abordar el
avión nos encerraron para calmarnos
algunas mujeres fueron golpeadas ellos
golpearon a hombres y mujeres
a su llegada a las personas fueron
sometidas a controles administrativos y
pruebas pcr pero las autoridades
haitianas temen no poder asistir a los
recién llegados
el problema es que estas personas no
aceptan las deportaciones forzadas
porque esa es la razón por la que
dejaron a haití no quieren vivir en
haití incluso si tuviéramos el centro
mejor equipado del mundo para recibirlos
no lo aceptarían porque para ellos haití
es el infierno tras una extensa y
compleja travesía estos migrantes
vuelven al casillero de salida con menos
recursos y más incertidumbre que antes